voilà soirée théâtre ce soir sur antenne
2 et jean fouquet gilbert kahn et
jacques weber vous propose une toute
nouvelle émission et à l'intendant pour
vous mettre l'eau à la bouche
le retour de michèle morgan alassane à
partir de jeudi
michel maure grand retour à la scène en
fait c'est la deuxième fois qu'on vous
voit sur scène à paris oui c'est la
première fois c'était il ya deux ans à
vous dans une pièce de françoise dorin
le tout pour le tout pour le tout et
cette fois ci c'est chéri de colette
alors on se demande si c'est pas une
toute nouvelle carrière pour vous
finalement puisque le cinéma c'est fini
apparemment plus de films est en tout
cas bien le moment c'est fini pour le
moment et je suis très heureuse de jouer
sur une scène je trouve que ça me donne
des possibilités une gamme et une
liberté que l'on ne connaît pas beaucoup
dans le cinéma à cause des caméras du
son des lumières et sur une scène je
bouge comme comme je lé naturellement
d'après la mise en scène de jean laurent
cochet mais à l'intérieur de cette mise
en scène je me sens très libre et c'est
une sensation extrêmement agréable bon
mais vous n'êtes pas pour autant perdu
pour l'écran quand même j'espère que non
georges big ou de nous présenter un
petit peu cette recette piège chéri donc
de colette
oui bien dans dans chéri colette raconte
l'histoire d'un monde où plus exactement
d'un demi monde c'est une histoire
d'amour entre une femme pygmalion et un
très jeune homme chéri et il est évident
que cette femme les ducs à la manière
d'une mère un pur et il est évident
aussi que chérie va lui échapper et dans
la seine que nous allons voir au lait de
l'or qui joue la vraie mère de shérif
vient annoncer à michel mauran la
protectrice qu'elle va le marié à une
fille de son âge alors ses deux enfants
genest fortune amour
qu'est ce qui te fait rien hoyer
cette idée que la vie souvent belle
devant une jeune fille qu'on donne à
cherry une jeune fille a chéri autant
jeter une biche à lévriers comment
comment lui qui est si doux que sisyphe
quoi si quoi qu'est-ce que tu en sais
que je suis jamais là depuis quand nous
sommes toutes seules voyons charlotte au
tu t'énerves 1 mais mu mais j'aurais dû
ménager davantage comprends très bien
une surprise comme ces noms charlotte
unis comprend rien il n'y a pas de
surprise
je t'attendais quand chéri était haut
comme ça je ne m'inquiétais que de
l'enlever ou domestiques de temps en
temps pour pour le mener au bois le
faire goûter je le revois encore dans
son costume de velours noir ont voté une
créature de légende ça je me rappelle un
jour de fête des fleurs où il était
ainsi presque nue dans les rouleaux les
ondes me fais les pièces alors moi j'ai
jamais pu voir un chien qui souffla golf
abandonné s'en mêler de ce qui ne me
regarde pas mais il avait toujours pas
de mine quand je ramenais de la campagne
je lui ai toujours donné ce qu'il lui
fallait
je me fiais toi tu peux de pierre -
charlotte mais à présent j'ai fini tu
t'attendais j'étais sûr que tu
reviendrais pour le jeu reprend del re
passer à une autre femme de confiance
vis à vis l'hameçon force tu repasses
trouve pas la chose l'aide non plus donc
michel monredon série au théâtre des
variétés à partir de jeudi à paris bien
sûr un sens nombre de